before uber went public uber was the
highest value private stock company in
the world and it hadn't been established
just ten years ago despite this vast
growth who has faced fierce opposition
in the taxi industry and government
regulators and sustains billions of
dollars of loss of every single year so
how is it we'll be able to push through
all of these struggles and dominate the
market make sure to stick around till
the end to find out welcome to hobbies
so it all started in Paris when two
friends Travis kalanick and Garrett camp
met at LeWeb an annual tech conference
in 2008 both of these men were very
established successful people cal nick
has sold read swoosh to Akamai
Technologies for 19 million dollars in
camp had sold StumbleUpon to eBay for 75
million no rumor suggests that the
concept of uber was created and the two
men could not find a cab after
conference one winter night after the
conference however the two men went
their separate ways but can't pursue
this idea in San Francisco by buying the
domain rubric Abbott com in early 2009
Campo still the CEO of StumbleUpon but
he was working on prototype for uber
cabin by summer he had persuaded CalNet
to join the company as chief incubator
at first the service was tested in New
York with just three cars the service
officially launched in San Francisco in
just a couple of months later in May
2010 originally Brian Graves was
appointed as CEO but just a couple of
months later in December of 2010
kalmyk took over as CEO and Ryan graves
as appointed as CEO Oh
uber cab quickly gained popularity due
to its ease and simplicity and by
October of 2010 whoever completed his
first major funding campaign of 1.25
million dollars and with that uber was
off to a great start
unfortunately there are problems arose
from the very beginning the San
Francisco municipal transportation
agency gave him a cease and desist order
studying at their name used the word cab
uber cab quickly responded to this claim
I remained the word cab
and buying the domain uber calm in early
2011 they went on another funding
campaign raising over 11 million dollars
this allowed them to expanded to New
York Seattle Boston Chicago Washington
DC and even abroad in Paris they raised
another 37 million dollars that same
year from Menlo Ventures Jeff Bezos
and Goldman Sachs they also launched
uber X which was a less expensive hybrid
car service as a poster original black
car service but there has been a lot of
international opposition to Ober for
example in 2014
taxi drivers in London Berlin Paris and
Madrid caged large-scale protests
against uber taxi companies were arguing
that Walker did have to pay hefty
licensing fees and bypass many local
laws which created unfair competition
this case went to the top court in
Europe and in December of 2016
lewbert lost her license to operate in
London Transport for London or PFF
determined that Walker just wasn't fit
to hold license in their city but uber
claims that London caved to certain
people which limits consumer choice
unfortunately for uber and their 40,000
drivers in London this van lasted for a
year and a half until June 26 2018 remit
judge overturned the ban the judge
allowed the company to operate for 15
months under licence with several
conditions but these are just
international issues uber had a handful
of issues back in the States as well
more issues arose when news came out
that Oprah's charging drivers commission
based on pre-tax versus post tax affairs
this results in millions of dollars of
losses for New York drivers and uber
stated that this was simply accounting
error and they would fix it as quickly
as possible
however this raised several questions on
who exactly paid the taxes for uber
drivers advocacy group argues that uber
avoids paying taxes at the expense of
the drivers and New York Times actually
found evidence of this this had led to
hundreds of millions of dollars of
losses and by June 13 2017
a New York judge ruled that uber must
reduce drivers as employees instead of
independent contractors this opened up
drivers for the potential
receiving employee benefits and this was
significantly hurt Uber's bottom line in
August of 2018 a restriction on licenses
was imposed by new york city this
obstructed who were containing any new
licenses for the ride-sharing service
for the next all months and these are
simply just the problems that arose in
New York over the years there has been
one consistent problem with just a
bureau backlash against urging prices
surge pricing is an automatic algorithm
that increases fair prices based on
supply and demand as a result when
there's a lot of demand the fares go up
a lot for example is it very common in
major airports in their peak times but
sometimes the surge pricing is
absolutely outrageous in 2011 in New
Year's Eve there is so much demand that
surprising soared to 7 times the normal
fare and as you could already guess this
field a lot of negative feedback surge
pricing also caused an outrage during a
snowstorm in New York in December 2013
since then uber has promised a cap surge
pricing in New York City during
blizzards storms uber also had ferocious
competition from lives even though lyft
is significantly slotted uber they were
gaining market share very quickly in
2014 both companies claimed that drivers
employes in the opposite company tried
to sabotage each other they claimed that
these people regularly order and cancel
buys on each of those services kalmyk
has even openly admitted for trying to
undermine lives fundraising efforts and
Vanity Fair article
as a result despite slips small size it
definitely cost over simple problems
uber has greatly diversified their
revenue stream by adding additional
services one of which is uber easy which
is a merchant food delivery program
which basically delivers food from
nearby restaurants they also added uber
pull in an effort to make fares cheaper
for the consumer with uber pull uber
drivers pick up multiple passengers in
one
override and this is much cheaper when
compared to Hooper egg
and uber black on top of this what we
lost their own credit card in
partnership with a Barclays the uber
visa card has reportedly free and comes
the hundred dollar starting bonus but
using this card consumers can get cash
back on dining errors and certain online
transactions clearly were as diversified
their revenue streams uber has also
invested big amounts or even quired
several other companies on July 9th 2018
uber announced that you invest in lime
an electric scooter rental company lime
offers lightweight skewers for rent
around the city and it is valued at over
1.1 billion dollars uber plans to
promote lime through its app and even
put its own logo on their scooters uber
made similar efforts and jump bikes
before completely according the company
for about two hundred million dollars in
April of 2018 so not only is over
continuously eyeing additional services
but they are also investing other
companies as well these significant
investments along with their additional
services can explain this significant
increase in debt year after year and
finally one of the biggest deterrence
was CEO kalmyk himself he may have been
a great leader and be very smart
but he had a terrible public image a
female uber engineer exposed a company
for sexist behavior at three thousand
word blog post this led to a
full-fledged investigation which led to
47 recommendations and firing over 20
staff members the following Montford
know better has left release that
confirmed the sexist culture in uber
came from it top down from calment
himself he was also caught on camera
arguing with a ruber driver to lower
peers which simply just destroys public
image even further there are several
CEOs are hated by companies staff
members but this year was publicly hated
counting quinoa the most controversial
CEOs along with Mike Jeffries of
Abercrombie & Fitch people simply did
not want a supported company last led
best at the CEO and as a result they
turned over to other ride-sharing apps
and slipped finally on June 21st
2017 Callan
designed after a revolt from
shareholders derrick ashraf lafayette
the CEO of Expedia took over after him
since then fortunately for uber the
market share has remained pretty stable
at little less than 70% the removal of
kalmyk definitely has helped the company
at least in the short term in the end
who has really been able to dominate the
ride cherry market as there isn't first
to enter this market never really
diversify the revenue streams as well on
top of this their push technology or by
strongly promoting self-driving cars
even major issues in almost every single
realm for example just last year they
had a huge accident with their
driverless cars my traveler's car hit a
pedestrian this was actually a fail of
accident and they had to stop
all testing for a couple of months but
in July of 2018 they resumed in
Pittsburgh uber has faced a lot of
issues but they have pretty much pushed
through every single one except for the
financial ones there are several reasons
that uber is losing money but the main
reason is due to vast expansion across
the globe Lopes truly revolutionized
ride services that I continued do so by
pushing forward driverless cars but only
time will tell if Ober will be able to
maintain its high level of success by
turning around their finances before
it's too late
but that's all I have for you guys on
uber make a comment down below what
company you would like me to cover next
also if you guys liked this video make
you drop a like and consider subscribing
like some more videos just like this one
but all then I'm Lauren I'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]